salut à tous cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par Opera GX Opera GX c'est un
navigateur qui permet de limiter
l'utilisation du CPU et de la RAM pour
éviter le lag c'est des intégrations
directes de twitch et de discord et
c'est aussi des fonds d'écran animés qui
s'exécutent en douceur en arrière-plan
de votre navigateur et pour en profiter
un maximum je regarde ça sur mon grand
écran ça fait une heure qu'on t'attend
pour tourner là qu'est-ce que tu brans
là attends c'est un fond d'écran animé
sur Opera GX
[Musique]
mais c'est aussi plein de trucs pour
vous faciliter la vie compatible avec
toutes les extensions chrome outil
d'importation rapide pour importer les
paramètres de votre ancien navigateur
jusqu'à GX et une fonctionnalité
dernière vidéo waouh grâce à ça je peux
revoir les 12 dernièr vidéo que freed a
téléchargé
regardez et vous pourrez également
télécharger ce magnifique fond d'écran
Joueur du Grenier tellement fluo qu'il
rend la vue aux aveugles 100 % garantie
alors allez-y télécharger Opera et
installer avec le lien dans la
[Musique]
description 1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
salut à tous adapter un film en jeu
vidéo vous le savez c'est très facile
put pourquoi vous faites ça mais quoi
merde enfin non c'est pas facile mais en
tout cas ça a été fait très souvent et
dans l' mission Joueur du Grenier on a
des dizaines et des dizaines d'exemples
de ça mais dans l'autre sens c'est
certainement encore moins cile et
pourtant de nombreuses personnes s'y
sont essayé Mario Sonic Uncharted Tomb
Raider Warcraft Mortal Kombat dont on
avait déjà parlé ça peut arrivriver hein
des fois que ça soit pas trop mal comme
le premier silentill par exemple ou
détective Pikachu mais dans la majorité
des cas ça donne en général des films
pas ouf dont certains s'en sont fait une
spécialité comme veball qui a réalisé
énormément d'adaptations de jeux en film
ou Paul Anderson et justement Paul
Anderson c'est aussi la même personne
qui a réalisé toute la saga Resident
Evil on a déjà parlé de Resident Evil
dans un vieux papier grrenier et tout le
monde connaît cette saga qui a commencé
en 95 sur Playstation 1 un jeu qui a
redéfini le genre du Survival Aurore le
jeu est une révolution par ses
placements de caméra qui favorise
l'angoisse et le côté claustrophobe les
munitions à gérer en faible quantité et
justement Resident Evil c'est aussi les
premiers jeux à apporter des scènes
cinématiques avec des vrais acteurs et
aussi un gameplay même très inspiré du
cinéma pas étonnant donc ce soit aussi
les premiers jeux où le public se soit
dit ah bah tiens ça ferait peut-être un
bon film et justement ça a été fait
Resident Evil c'est la saga de jeux VI
vidéo qui a eu le droit au plus
d'adaptations avec un total de se films
dont six sortis entre 2002 et 2016 avec
comme personnage principal Alice joué
par Mila Jovovic et un 7e film sorti il
y a quelques mois à peine un Rebout du
nom de Resident Evil welcome to Racon
City et justement ce Rebo de Resident
Evil et un constat c'est que les gens
avaient beaucoup reproché au film
précédent de ne absolument pas suivre la
trame des jeux alors certes il y a
Wesker il y a umbrellaa il y a cl
Redfield mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
les jeux et c'est aussi ce que pensait
le réalisateur de de ce film Johan
Robert qui justement voulait revenir à
la base des jeux le film commence donc
dans un orphelina avec un concert de
Carla Bruni à côté
[Musique]
oui alors ces enfants qui chantent là
pour vous faire peur vous allez beaucoup
les entendre dans ce film et allez on va
bourrer tout ce qui peut faire peur les
gros plans sur les poupées les clown la
boîte à musique une photo du prix de
l'essence le violon qui Queen et on y
croise rapidement Lisa Trevor qui essaie
de se lier d'habité avec et chr Redfield
comme nous l'explique le film de manière
si fine
attendez c'est Redfield c'est ça Chris
et Claire Redfield
Redfield Chris et Claire Redfield mais
monsieur on est là depuis 5 ans oui
depuis 5 ans dans l'orphelina de Racon
City monsieur ça va oui je vous souhaite
une bonne nuit c'est moi monsieur Birkin
le médecin chef qui vous souhaite une
bonne
nuit ça c'est un mur retour dans le
présent donc en 98 on retrouve clairire
redfied dans le camion de Monsieur
exposition ah oui c'est vrai que vous
allez voir votre frère c'est ça il
habite par ici vous avait dit un Racon
City il reste rien à parler à ton laveur
depuis quebrella commence à s'en aller
mais je le sais qui renverse une
passante sur la route mais celle-ci se
relève et disparaîen c'est pas ma je
sais j'ai D dans le champ de vision du
mec d'ailleurs mais c'est pas grave car
pendant ce tempsl à Racon City les
membres du stars sont en train de boire
un café avec parmi eux Léon Kennedy tu
aurais tiré sur ton partenaire pendant
l'entraînement c'est vrai ou non et
aussi ton paternel est très important
dans la police alors il a pu tirer
d'affaire mais je le sais alors on va
dire quelque chose déjà pour commencer
ce film est insupportable avec toutes
ces scènes d'exposition une scène
d'exposition c'est une scène où le film
va essayer de transmettre des
informations au spectates pour la
compréhension de monde mais il faut
aussi que ça ait du sens et qu'on a'est
pas l'impression que le film s'adresse
directement et volontairement aux
spectateurs typiquement he la plupart
d'entre vous savent que wal Spencer
était le fondateur d'ombrella
Corporation et le manoir était son lieu
d'habitation jusqu'à qui parle comme ça
en vrai Sébastien RCIA amis et collègu
depuis plus de 15 ans avec qui je
réalise les vidéos joueurs du grenier je
vois que tu es en train de boire un café
dans ce café en Bretagne région du
Nord-Ouest de la France connu pour pour
sa pluie et ses autoroutes gratuites
bref dans cette ville de Racon City
quelque chose de louche semble se passer
qu'est-ce qu'il a votre
œil je sais pas ça fait ça depuis de
semaines alors quand ça vient de l'œil
c'est pas normal claire revient donc à
Racon City pour voir son frère qui
habite toujours pour l'informer qu'elle
a découvert que la ville serait
empoisonné par l'eau toute cette ville a
été empoisonnée mais son frère qui ne
lui a pas pardonné d'avoir quitté la
ville ne l'écoute pas et part travailler
de son côté pendant ce tempsl les
alarmes de la ville se mettent à
retentir ordonnant le couvrefeu ceci est
un message de Corporation pour votre
sécurité veuillez rester chez vous et
attendre de nouvelles instructions alors
déjà réveilleer les gens au milieu de la
nuit pour leur dire de rester chez eux
c'est vraiment complètement con et de
c'est bizarre ce monde là où c'est une
société privée qui donne des ordres aux
gens et pas les
autorités ici
céréallex restez chez vous passe rien et
nous voilà donc dans les locaux de la
police avec l'ensemble des membres du
stars cette unité d'élite d'intervention
ah on me dit dans mon oriette que en
fait les stars dans ce film c'est la
police de la ville ce qui est en fait
teacniquement la police municipale en
fait mais tu as pas
d'oreillettes il en sait trop tu le
maintenant Léon se fait donc encore une
fois de plus pisser dessus par son chef
qui lui dit d'aller faire l'accueil
tandis que le reste de l'équipe décide
de prendre l'hélico de la police
municipale pour aller chercher l'équipe
Alpha qui a disparu en allon en Manor
Spencer c'est le manoir
Spencer de de Resident Evil sur
Playstation c'est le même manoir qu'on
voit dans le jeu ta gueule pendant ce
temps-là à l'accueil le chauffeur du
camion qu'on a vu au début du film qui a
été mordu par son chien entre-temps
s'est transformé en zombie et vient
s'exploser sur les grilles du
commissariat pardon non mais dans un
moment comme ça tu dois avoir la
température qui passe de 12 à 90°gr en
une seconde les vitres qui volent en
éclat à cause du souffle de l'explosion
le souffle de l'explosion lui-même les
murs qui tremblent le bruit comment
c'est possible de rien remarquer il a
perdu ses 5 sens
oh
[ __ ] ok je je rappelle qu'à ce stade
là du film la police ne sait pas qu'il y
a des zombies encore oh mon dieu mais
cette femme est en train de
s'étouffer et voilà elle s'étouff plus
oh mon dieu cette femme est en train
d'accoucher tous les personnages dans ce
film sont absurdes le chef de la police
qui abandonne son poste au premier
zombies ce qui en fait un très mauvais
flic ou un très mauvais traître au choix
le mieux étant Léon dédicace à à tous
ses fans dans les jeux puisque dans ce
film c'est une colossale victime qui se
fait Bolos par son patron et ses
collègues qui est maladroit et se fait
piquer son arme par un mec de 30 kg
enfermé derrière une grille qui a une
tête à faire la sortie des collèges
lâchez-moi [ __ ] e oh c'est fais-moi
sortir tout de suite
monarme enfin c'est pas mieux le mec
dans la cellule qui est un genre de
complotiste parano déjà au courant de
tout ce que fait un brellaa est enfermé
avec un zombie mais se fait quand même
bouffer comme un con sérieux il le sait
que le gars à côté de lui va le bouffer
il le sait il le dit même mais bien sûr
que non il va pas bien regardez-le
ouvrez cette [ __ ] de grille ah si
seulement j'avais quelque chose pour me
défendre rve donc au manoir Spencer
l'équipe Bravo parti chercher l'équipe
Alpha tombe nez à nez avec un mort
vivant
ouais ouais bon j'ai la r mais ça reste
débile c'est filmé comme une révélation
en mode genre oh mon dieu il y a des
zombies dans ce film alors queon en a vu
50 avant bref alors que tout était
silencieux et désert dans cette immense
pièce vide soudainement 400 zombies
sortent de mon cul pour sauter sur les
héros alors ça c'est le troisème type de
zombie le plus fréquent dans le cinéma
vous savez on a trois types de zombies
on a les zombies à la Romero ce sont
ceux qui avancent doucement antiubant à
la walking dead on a les zombies de type
infectés ce sont ceux qui courent très
vite façon un peu 28 jours plus tard et
on a le troème type de zombie justement
comme dans Resident Evil qu'on va
appeler les zombies du spectacle et
justement pour l'émission Joueur du
Grenier nous avons pu en interviewer un
oui vous savez c'est pas facile d'être
un zombie du spectacle et quand je vois
mes collègues qui se contentent de
marcher tout droit en
faisant franchement c'est pas terrible
je veux dire il y a quand même un
savoir-faire à maîtriser déjà la clé je
pense que c'est la discrétion c'est
important pour faire un bon effet là par
exemple mon collègue va arriver dans le
dos du gentil qui ne l'a pas encore vu
donc il va pas lui sauter dessus
directement ça serait pas très correct
on préfère temporiser on et paf le
deuxième collègue qui était caché
trancène ah c'est fluide il y a une
bonne technique alors ah oui ça c'est
une de mes scènes favorites l'idée c'est
d'avancer uniquement quand le briquet
s'allume et au moment où on pense que
mon collègue s'apprête à attaquer et
bien non plus personne ni à
droite ni à gauche on temporise et là le
deuxième collègue arrive tout doucement
et paf le premier qui avait totalement
disparu saute sur la victime c'est
vraiment du beau boulot allez duner on y
va maintenant tu fais une roulade devant
Chris Redfield allez on y va
délicatement voilà agressif quand même
donc voilà tu sors du champ et le
deuxième approche et toi tu vas attaquer
par le côté ah j'adore ma troupe ils
sont vraiment comme ça bref pendant que
l'équipe Alpha affronte des morts
vivants dans le manoir Spencer et que
Wesker regarde un let play du jeu sur
son téléphone pour s'échapper claire
Léon et le chef de la police qui sont
bloqués dans Racon City parce que
Umbrella bloque les sorties se rendent à
l'orphelina pour prendre un raccourci
jusqu'au manoir Spencer qui serait la
seule manière de s'échapper de la ville
avant 6h du matin heure à laquelle la
ville entière va exploser avec l'aide de
Lisa Trevor les héros vainquent de
liqueur et Lisa leur montre le raccourci
pour
s'enfuir merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendez il me semble que la ville va
exploser non merci Lisa mon ami
d'enfance merci pour tout ce que tu as
fait pour moi je tellement désolé qu'il
n'y ait que de plac dans cet ascenseur
c'est terrible parce que quand tu la
vois on dirait vraiment qu'elle veut
venir en fait des fois elle fait des
petits mouvements comme ça pour avancer
tu sais non non désolé c'est marqué bref
évidemment fusion de deux jeux Resident
Evil oblige le scénario force un peu
tout ce petit monde à se rencontrer au
même endroit pour des raisons un petit
peu tirées par les cheveux avec d'un
côté Chris et Jill qui poursuivent
Wesker qui s'est enfu depuis le Manor
Spencer de l'autre Léon éclair depuis
l'orphelina et enfin le docteur Birkin
et sa famille qui lui essaie de
récupérer des échantillons tout le monde
se croise Birkins récupère le virus Wes
tukin Wes mais avant de mourir Birkins
s'inject le virus qui le transforme en
un monstre condamné à prononcer des
dialogues écrits par un enfant de 8 ans
comment ta s peutêtre si intelligente
alors que toi CHR tu es B
mé comme dans les jeux les héros ESS de
s'échapper de RAC City par un train
souterrain mais sont rattrapés par
Birkins en forme de mutant Chris vise
dans les points faibles de la cutine
PlayStation 3 mais plus de munition
est-ce la fin pas du tout car
heureusement Léon arrive allez Léon tout
le film tua été une mer mais c'était
uniquement pour mieux sublimer ce
momentl où tu vas briller allez c'est
ton
moment le gros
vain ok bah tant pis
ok il y a aucune chance que qui que ce
soit a survécu à une explosion de
lanceroquette comme ça dans un vagon
fermé à partir de ce momentl du film ils
sont tous morts et ça se passe dans leur
tête et puis comment tu as trouvé un
lanceroquet dans un traain abandonné un
lanceerquet je l'ai trouvé en première
classe sérieusement tu as trouvé ça où
ti il est temps de finir ce film de
merde ah d'ailleurs grosse journée pour
la petite Cherry Berkin qui a fu une
invasion zombie vu son père se faire
tuer être ressuscité en monstre
réabattre par un lance-roquet et
regardez pas de problème elle prend la
vie du bon côté bref Birkins est vaincu
Racon City explose les vaches s'envol
les héros sont vivants et on finit sur
la scène postcédit avec Wesker qui n'est
pas mort il était juste enseveli sous
100 millions de tonnes de décombre avec
le personnage de adawang qui lui donne
des lunettes de soleil parce que quand
tu ressuscites et bien tu as mal aux ye
jeu oh oh c'est c'est comme dans le jeu
c'est comme dans le jeu dans westker
dans le jeu il a des lunettes noires
aussi j'ai la ref et c'est comme dans le
jeu tu peux arrêter de parler comme ça
s'il te plaît je peux pas m'en empêcher
il faut que quelqu'un m'aide alors ce
film est noté comme étant le pire film
Resident Evil avec une note de 5,2 sur Y
MDB et on peut voir mou de commentaires
disant que ce film n'est pas aussi bien
que les six films précédents pas aussi
bon que les films de Mila Jovovic
comparé à ça je préfère largement les
films de Mila Jovovic allez plutôt
revoir les films de Mila Jovovic elle
est bonne Mila Jovovic attends mais
c'est toi qui a c'est pas le sujet
Sébastien la saga Resident Evil aussi
appelé les films Resident Evil avec Mila
Jovovic faut dire qu'en fait l'actrice
est tellement au centre de cette
histoire que tout le monde se fout du
Real ou même des personnages du jeu la
saga comporte 6 films donc Resident Evil
Resident Evil apocalypse Resident Evil
extinction Resident Evil afterli
Resident Evil rétribution Resident Evil
explosion et Resident Evil final chapter
alors c'est sympa t ces tites de film
mais du coup c'est quand même un peu
compliqué de savoir lequel est le 2 le 3
le 4 parce que je veux dire ok donc
l'extinction non alors attends c'est
l'apocalypse qui est avant l'extinction
et rétribution donc le châtiment en
français c'est après ou c'est avant
afterli l'au-delà alors d'après la Bible
c'est beaucoup mieux le boulot pour
faire des meubles que le pain alors je
crois que tu t'es trompé de livre et
merde mais dans quelle église je vais
moi le dimanche alors on va pas se faire
chronologiquement le détail des six
films il nous faudrait
10h mais on va quand même essayer de
faire un gros récapitulatif des
scénarios la saga nous raconte donc
l'histoire de
Alice incarné par milajovic qui se
réveille amnésique dans un laboratoire
secret dirigé par le docteur Isaac sous
la ville de Racon City appartenant à
Umbrella Corporation à l'intérieur un
virus mortel transformant les gens en
zombies s'est échappé le centre est
alors mis en quarantaine et un commando
arrive pour comprendre ce qui se passe
mais Unia du nom de l'arène rouge essaie
de tuer tout le monde pour contenir le
secré pendant ce tempsl Alice qui est
donc un agent de sécurité qui vient à
peine de se réveiller et qui comprend
rien à tout ce bordel essaie de
s'échapper chose qu'elle n'arrive pas à
faire puisqu'elle se refait capturer
avec son copain elle se réveille donc au
début du deuxème film et le virus s'est
échappé dans la ville de Racon City avec
l'aide de Jill Valentine une policière
fasciste ce Ty fou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
feux c'est
je vois pas d'autres mots pour décrire
ce que je viens de voir mais quoi il est
votre personnage là de votre jeu de
merde en mini jupe comme dans le jeu ê
content non Jill Alice et quelques
autres personnages essaient de
s'échapper de la ville avant son
explosion pendant que son copain du
premier film a été transformé en
nemmésis un monstre avec un lanceroquet
et un impère noir mais heureusement pour
Alice et au pouvoir de
l'amour mat je suis vraiment désolé
oh [ __ ] je vais avoir besoin d'alcool
mais tu peux pas ben c'est peut-être le
bon moment pour commencer Nemesis change
de camp et attaque Umbrella la ville
explose à la fin de ce deuxième film et
Alice se refait capturer mais réussit de
nouveau à s'échapper et ce coup-ci elle
a des super
pouvoirs alors est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir des explic non ah oui la ville a
explosé mais aucune conséquence pour le
scénario hein des preuves viennent
anéantir la véracité des reportages ce
nétait qu'une blague de mauvais coup les
fait sur la cassette ont été totalement
démentis ce n'était qu'un sombre canular
organisateur du canular g Valentin et
Carlos Oliva sont actuellement
recherchés par la police comment ça
c'est faux c'est une ville qui a été
rasée par une explosion nucléaire ça
devrait pas être trop difficile à
vérifier je pense tout le monde est mort
j'ai littéralement les pieds au centre
du cratère vous le voyez bien là quand
même qui nous dit que c'est pas vous qui
creuser ce trou là
je perds mes cheveux à cause des
radiations quand même ah ben moi aussi
je perds mes cheveux c'est peut-être
votre Champo il fait ça j'ai un zombie
qui est en train de me manger ah ben
vous voyez bien qu'il reste déjà viv les
personnages se sont donc échappés mais
le virus lui aussi est dans la nature et
c'est le troisème film nous sommes
dorénavant 5 ans après le virus est
devenu tellement méchant qu'il a asséché
la planète et foutu du sable partout il
a sécher les lacs et les rivières les
forêts devenaient des déserts connard de
virus salut je parie qu'il a aussi
augmenté les impôts et fait travailler
les enfants c'est donc la fin du monde
mais on apprend qu'Al c'est la clé pour
trouver un vaccin Umbrella ESS donc de
la cloner mais ça n'est pas suffisant il
leur faut l'original le docteur Isaac et
Wesker le président der décid donc de
partir chercher la vraie Alice qui
quelque part dans le désert en se
servant d'une nouvelle variante de super
zombie donc ça ça nous aider oui mais je
pour l'instant je sais pas hein je je
sais pas j'y travaille ils enferment
donc quelquesuns de ces super zombies
dans des gros conteneurs en métal pour
la capturer enfin le pays est grand
enfin je veux dire même si Alice et ses
alliés tomberaient dessus par hasard
enfin je veux dire les les les
statistiques sont sont impossibles et
puis même admettons ils tombent sur le
container qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit
qu'ils sont assez stupides pour l'ouvrir
franchement c'est ça dépasse
l'entendement ah oui et c'est aussi
c'est des zombies du
spectacle on y va on y je bouge pasou on
attend à droit on y va
d'accord non je dis TR TR ah oui et j'ai
pas dit mais ils essaient aussi de
manipuler Alice en utilisant le fait
qu'elle ait été hypnotisée et qu'elle
peut être contrôlée par un satellite
d'Umbrella depuis la fin du deuxème film
programme Alice activé ouais désolé je
peux pas préciser tous les petits détail
mais ça ne marche pas parce que Alice
elle est tellement badasse qu'elle fait
péter le satellite en le regardant c'est
genre le satellite il baisse les yeux tu
vois heureusement qu'elle est super
précise pour viser ce satellite qui est
à 200 km auudessus d'elle parce qu'elle
aurait regardé un demi millimèt à
côté bref Alice va donc au laboratoire
secret d'Umbrella sous le désert pour
tuer Isaac le méchant docteur qui
entreetemps s'est transformé en monstre
mais le combat est difficile et Alice
est sur le point de perdre quand soudain
alors que tout semble perdu quelqu'un
vient à sa rescousse
merdez vous voulez dire qu'il y a
quelqu'un d'autre qui va lui sauver la
vie attends que ça veut dire qu'il y a
quelqu'un d'autre que résidente marisou
Alice dans cette [ __ ] de série de film
qui va faire quelque chose de classe
mais qui est donc ce personnage
mystérieux qui a pu non c un cyclone
c'est fou quoi ce film est tellement
égocentrique que l'héroïne même quand
elle est sauvé par quelqu'un d'autre
c'est aussi elle-même donc Alice tue le
docteur Isaac libère ses clones et c'est
le début du 4e film et à partir de ce
moment-l on entre dans un ngot trip
absolu en fait pire que pire que
maintenant donc Alice part pour Tokyo
pour aller au laboratoire secret
d'Umbrella sous Tokyo pour aller tuer
Wesker avec l'aide de son armée de
marisou et puis là allez là la saga elle
se relâche comme un mec qui se serait
retenu de péter toute la journée elle a
plus rien à [ __ ] et allez et Pan et
boum boum et nique la gravité c'est
parti il plus rien à [ __ ] allez il y a
des katanas il y a des soldats il y a
des gros flings il y a des shuriken il y
a des bœufs Bonet maquillés qui font des
cabrioles en talent aiguille avec des
tenues qui moulent le FI elle fait des
tremblements de terre en tant avec les
pieds il y a des explosions face Dragon
Ball zou que c'est pas très pour toi
tout
ça mais c'est n'importe quoi elle est
complètement pétée je veux dire en face
ils peuvent rien faire mais comment ils
vont faire pour la suite
quoi tous les pouvoirs que tu avais
puissance vitesse guérison accéléré et
bien tu vas devoir t'en passer ah
attends il y a une patche les CL disparu
la roulade a éténerfée de 50 % les
dégâts de Alice ont été grandement
réduits et nous avons rééquilibré
lesouvoirs du personnage principal afin
de mieux coller à la vision originale
des développeurs [ __ ] ils ont détruit
mon ma attendez après il y a des
explications quand mêmece que c'est que
ça un sérum qui envahit ton organisme
qui neutralise les cell oh regardez le
Virus T c'est des des lettres en forme
de T mais qu'est-ce que j'ai
[Musique]
docteur après avoir fait exploser la
base Tok ensuite chercher des survivants
en Alaska et retrouve Claire seul et
amnésique comment fait pour faire des
allerretour depuis Tokyo alors que le
monde est détruit et il y a plus d'avion
je sais pas une autre question alors
j'ai quelques questions Alice récupère
donc Claire Redfield et les deux partent
chercher Arcadia qui est censé être un
avre de paix en le cherchant il retourne
vers les États-Unis et tombe par hasard
sur quatre survivants sur le toit d'un
immeuble et là paf le hasard il y avait
le frère de clerc dedans je m'appelle ch
bah c'est fou le hasard
le monde est petit le frère de CLIRE
chris est dans une
prison et une fois libéré après une
scène d'action complètement stupide où
encore une fois la physique se fait
[ __ ] sans même se faire offrir un ver
avant ils partent tous ensemble vers
l'océan pour trouver Arcadia mais en
fait c'était un piège parce que Wesker
était dans le bateau donc les personnage
tue Wes je je veux dire Alice tue Wesker
absolument toute seule et sans aide
parce qu'elle est trop forte et trop
belle aussi d'ailleurs pendant que les
autres ne font absolument rien oh
Seigneur c'est complètement con mais
attends il si ils font quelque chose ils
ont le droit de lui tirer dessus quand
il est déjà mort toi on t'a assez
vu
e mais là patatra Umbrella arrive en
masse les héros sont piégés sur le
bateau mais que vont-ils faire c'est le
5e film Alice se fait capturer par Jill
qui est devenue méchante et travaille
pour un brellaard oui alors c'est parce
qu'en fait elle a un scarabet rouge qui
la rend méchant
et excusez-moi mais j'en peux plus de
ces scènes d'action là qu'est-ce que
c'est que ces conneries mais toutes les
scènes avec Alice dans tous les films ça
ressemble à
ça comment ça marche là elle a mis le
mode no clip bref elle se fait capturer
et se réveille dans un complexe
d'Umbrella ça fait quoi maintenant qu
fois 5 fois arrê de compter alors bon
bref cris quoi enfin je veux dire crris
éclair ils étaient sur le bateau il y a
2 secondes qui ah oui mais oui c'est
vrai regardons ce que ça fait si on
colle les deux films ensemble
[Musique]
calamité disparu
c'est vrai qu'ils auraient pu mettre une
explication quand même attendez je la
fais pour
vous je dois y aller ma planète a besoin
de
moi Chris et cl sont morts en retournant
sur leur planète je disais donc que
Alice a été capturé encore ils font des
tests sur elle évidemment elle se
réveille et s'échappe encore et découvre
qu'elle est dans un faux Tokyo construit
dans un sous-sol en Russie contrairement
au film d'avant où elle était dans le
vrai Tokyo mais qu'elle aller en Alaska
elle se rend compte que Umbrella ont
construit des fausses villes en sous-sol
un peu partout dans le monde qu'il
peuple avec des clones qu'ils infectent
avec le virus et qu'il filme se manger
entre eux pour l'envoyer à des
gouvernements et leur montrer ce que le
virus ferait ils ont recréé le centre de
New York ils ont simulé une épidémie
l'ont montré aux Russes et l'uront vendu
le virus ils ont simulé la même chose
sur Moscou et ont vendu le virus aux
américain même chose sur Tokyo ils
vendent le virus au chinois puis même
chose en Chine ils le vend japonais
exactement voilà parce que les
gouvernements ont vraiment très très peu
d'imagination faut comprendre et
d'ailleurs les zombes Russes c'est c'est
c'est un peu particulier visiblement ils
font de la moto ils conduisent des
bagnoles ils tirent avec des
lanceroquettes parce que du coup ce
virus qui est censé tuer les gens
là marche pas c'est de la merde et
maintenant comme vous pouvez le
constater grâce à ce virus les soldats
ennemis sont doravant vachement plus
fort et en plus il résiste au bal
ouais non on on va parler d'autes chose
en fait donc Alice s'est libérée du
complexe par Wesker qui maintenant est
devenu gentil parce qu'il trouve que
Umbrella va trop loin bon stop là j'ai
rien dit quand vous avez fait un virus
mortel qui tue les gens j'ai rien dit
quand vous avez fait exploser une ville
ni quand vous avez commencé à clonner
des gens et les tuer sans raison ni
quand Wesker envoie donc quelquesuns de
ses agents à Wong lon Kennedy et Barry
Burton ah oh c'est dans le jeu
pour libérer Alice et bon alors je zaape
l'intégralité du film vous aurez qu'à
aller le voir non franchement sans
déconnaé alleer le voir c'est une pépite
de débilité mais à la fin du film en
gros Jill Valentine est redevenu
gentille lon Kennedy est visiblement
devenu un agresseur sexuel pour une
raison qui m'échappe totalement dans
cette scène trop bizarre avec Ada Wong
et tout le monde se regroupe à la Maison
Blanche pour livrer le combat final
contre la Reine Rouge l'intelligence
artificielle de Umbrella qui a foutu
tout ce bordel toutes les pièces du
puzzle son sont prêtes tous les
personnages enfin presque tous sont là
c'est l'heure de Resident Evil le
chapitre final là j'ai hâte de voir tous
les personnages que j'aime enfin réunis
dans un seul et même [ __ ] de
merde
disparu tout le monde est retourné sur
sa planète ben on s'en fout tout ce dont
on a besoin de voir finalement he c'est
Mila Mila Mila Mila seul qui se bat
contre des dragons avec sa jeep ah oui
et w-ceker est devenu méchant aussi en
fait non ce type qui était à la tête de
plusieurs génocides nous a trahi et ce
film il faut savoir qu'il a coûté un
bras
bon pourtant il a coûté que 45 millions
de dollars ce qui est pas cher pour un
blockbuster non non je je veux dire
qu'il a littéralement coûté un bras il y
a une cascadeuse qui a doublé Mila qui a
perdu son bras pendant le tournage et le
producteur a refusé de lui payer
l'assurance ah après bon il y a pas mort
d'homme non plus alors si il y a eu
aussi un mort quelqu'un s'est fait
écraser par un Hummer pendant le
tournage d'ailleurs regardez ils ont
pris cette photo juste après le drame
non Bonon j'en sais rien pour la photo
mais disons que c'était juste pas le
meilleur choix pour illustrer l'article
qui parle de la mort de mec donc le
scénare alors en fait liya nommé la
Reine Rouge qui dans le film d'avant
rappelez-vous était méchante et ben en
fait maintenant elle est gentille parce
qu'en vrai lia elle est juste obligée de
détruire le monde mais en fait elle a
pas vraiment envie de le faire et donc
comme elle est programmée pour ne pas
faire de mal aux gens qui travaillent
pour Umbrella et bien elle demande donc
à Alice qui elle ne travaille pas pour
unbrella de retourner à Racon City pour
détruire le laboratoire secret qui avait
déjà explosé à la fin du 2 mais qui en
fait visiblement avait pas vraiment
explosé oh bah moi quand je fais un truc
de toute façon c'est du solide hein je
suis pas là pour beer les sandwich Alice
doit donc retourner à Racon City pour
arrêter les projets secrets d'Umbrella
et trouver l'antivirus non le vaccin
plutôt Umbrella a développé un antivirus
transporté par l'air
d'accord on prend lequel du coup Norton
avaste bref tout ça en moins de 48 he le
compte àbour est LAN
mais pourquoi parce que sinon tous les
humains du monde ils meurent mais enfit
mais comment mais je veux dire mais ça
fait 5 ans que c'est la fin du monde et
pourquoi 48 he il se passe quoi dans 48
je sais pas moi merde m'engueule pas
c'est dans le film c'est comme ça c'est
juste parce que c'est plus classe avec
un comptebour peut-être c'est tout
dans 48 he je dois récupérer ma 206 au
garage voilà pour ça j'ai mis dans le
Filmon je me rappelle pas donc il faut
réparer faut réparer ma bagnole et le
scénario donc se rend à Racon City et se
fait capturer par le docteur Isaac et
celui-là même qui était mort dans le 3è
film mais qui en fait est vivant je l'ai
fait exprès de dire que j'étais mort
parce qu'en fait ben dans le 3isè film
c'était un clone j'ai tué un clone oh
[ __ ] on est sur des niveaux de
scénario c'est c'est le feuilleton de
mamie à 14h30 le mardi
aprè docteur Isaac mais je croyaz que
vous étiez mort dans un accident à bord
néo ouais je le pensais aussi ma chère
Alice mais en réalité c'était un clone
qui était mort donc avec l'aide de
Claire Redfield qu'elle retrouve
purement par hasard aussiacon City
Alice alors c'est
fou tout petit et de quelques autres
survivants qui de toute façon meurent
tous peu après il réussissent à trouver
Wesker qui décongèle le docteur Isaac le
vrai parce qu'en fait les deux d'avant
c'était des
clones es peut-être mon clone mais frère
jumeau madri
[Musique]
Dios et ça y est nous avons enfin le
vrai plan des méchants la vraie
révélation de la machination d'Umbrella
le scénario central des six films
pourquoi est-ce que Umbrella a fait tout
ça si nous sommes ici ce n'est pas pour
parler de l'avenir de cette compagnie
nous sommes ici pour parler de la fin du
monde les maladies incurables
fleurissent des fondamentalistes réclame
notre destruction le réchauffement
climatique fera fond la population ne
cesse d'augmenter nous aurons atteint le
tau de surpopulation dans 50 manière ou
d'une autre notre monde touche à sa fin
je propose de mettre fin à ce
monde mais à nos conditions ok docteur
Isac enfin je sais que vous passez une
période assez compliquée avec votre
divorce mais au pire prenez une semaine
de congé donc docteur Isaac a détruit le
monde parce que sinon le monde il allait
être détr une sorte d'apocalypse
orchestré bah oui parce que construire
des répliques de capital sous la terre
et les peupl avec des clones on peut
mais recycler des déchets attendez on
n'est pas des surhommes et aussi
révélation de plus en réalité alice
n'est pas la vraie Alice originelle
c'est en réalité la clonene d'une
vieille Alice qui est la vice-présidente
du groupe Umbrella et également la
version adulte de la gamine qui a servi
à modéliser l'intelligence artificielle
de la Reine Rouge mon apparence et ma
voix ont été conçu à partir
d'enregistrement que le docteur Marcus
avait fait de sa fille je suis l'enfant
qu'elle était tu es la femme qu'elle
serait devenue attends alors toi tu es
le deuxième clone de elle et de moi pas
du tout attends ou là non et du coup
cette version âgée de Alice qui est
techniquement l'original possède donc 50
% des parts de Umbrella et Isaac en fait
attend que le conseil d'administration
de Umbrella se réveille de son sommeil
cryogénique pour chasser Alice vieille
de la société et lui prendre ses pars de
marché parce que sinon benah il peut
rien faire bien sûr ah benah oui il
faudrait pas qu'on se prinene un recours
au tribunal de commerce dans ce monde où
il y a déjà eu l'Apocalypse bref la
vieille Alice renvoie Wesker ce qui
annule sa protection au près de Lia ce
dernier tribuche se fait couper le pied
et meurt oui je rappelle au passage
qu'on parle du même personnage qui avait
survécu dans le film précédent après
s'être fait exploser le crâne et tirer
50 balles dans le torse mais bon je
suppose que le film a dû l'oublier c'est
la bagarre P pan boum boum voilà Alice
réussi à battre Isaac et à s'emparer du
vaccin l'antivirus ah oui pardon mais le
Hi c'est que si elle libère l'antivirus
Alice mourra aussi parce qu'elle possède
également le Virus T en elle mais peu
importe car c'est l'heure de l'ultime
sacrifice pour sauver la race humaine
laapogée de cette saga Resident Evil la
fin du parcours de ce personnage
christique de Alice incarné par Mila
Jovovic qui mourra en héroïne sous les
torrents de larmes de ses amis et des
spectateurs pour sauver l'humanité pas
du
tout mais pourquoi je suis encore en vie
parce que tu baises avec le réalisateur
voilà pourquoi
et le film ainsi que la saga toute
entière se finit sur lia donc elle-même
en version jeune qui la noie de
compliments en donc qui se noie de
compliments voilà tu es bien meilleur
que et c'est fini allez tu es trop forte
Mila franchement je suis un ordinateur
mais je kifferaiis trop re toi et puis
aussi prends mes souvenirs d'enfance et
puis tu es trop belle mais oui mais ce
n'est pas tout vous avez aussi gagné une
Toyota Corolla regardez
là-bas et c'est la fin de cette saga
alice n'est pas Jésus elle est même plus
forte que Jésus parce que même Jésus lui
il est mort c'est
nul donc vous l'avez compris tous ces
films sont une ode à la gloire de mil
Jovic c'est la définition d'une marisou
elle fait tout toute seule tout le temps
et bordel je pensais pas qu'on pouvait
faire pire que di Haris s Skywalker les
héros du jeu sont juste là pour montrer
qu'ils sont moins forts qu'elle si Paul
Anderson il avait réalisé un film
Pokémon il y aurait eu Mila joovic qui
serait arrivé en faisant casse-toi c'est
moi qui fait les éclairs il a attaque
éclair
elle sait se battre elle fait atterrir
des avions sur des logements du cru elle
sait tout piloté elle fait du Kung fou
elle peut vaincre des soldats d'élite
même en ayant les mains attachées dans
le dos et en étant suspendu par les
pieds elle a des super pouvoirs de la
Force ah oui elle est plus forte que le
scénario aussi elle voit à travers les
murs alors on n'est pas rentré dans les
détails de chaque film mais par exemple
dans le deuxième film on a des
personnages qui sont enfermés à un
moment dans une église en train
d'affronter des monstres ils ont pas
croisé Alice encore et
ah ben voilà c'est la 4e église où je
défonce les vitreux là enfin il se passe
un truc ici et quand tu sais que
l'actrice principale est en couple avec
le réalisateur dans la vraie vie et que
la fille qui incarne la Reine Rouge dans
le film est également la fille dans la
vraie vie du réalisateur et de l'actrice
principale du coup cette scène de fin
elle est incroyable on a papa qui filme
deux fois maman en train de parler à
leur filles pendant que maman regarde
des images réelles de sa fille de la
vraie vie dans le film cette saga c'est
le film de mariage le plus cher du monde
la dernière apparition d'un personnage
lié au jeu c'est c'est là voilà c'est le
genou de Claire Redfield qui se contente
d'écouter la alice jeune dire à la Alice
vieille qu'elle est trop cool et au
passage une petite pensée à tous les
gens de chez Capcom et à tous ces
personnages qui nous ont quitté sans
aucune explication pendant ce film
et pourtant finalement étrangement
d'ailleurs bah ces films ça a été un
carton un carton en terme d'entré et
financier et ils ont pas été détestés il
y a toute une génération qui a grandi
avec et qui a aimé films alors que bon
pourtant c'est clairement débile mais
c'est peut-être ça finalement voyez
peut-être que le réalisateur il a
compris ce quiétait une merde une vraie
merde c'est pas juste une merde parmi
d'autres c'est une merde sincère et
surtout c'est une merde généreuse et
plus important que tout c'est pas une
merde qui fait exprès d'être une merde
on n'est pas sur un niveau de genre
Shark nado vous voyez là déjà c'est pas
un avé parce que honnêtement c'est
tellement idiot qu'on rigole bien mais
en plus le film est tellement généreux
dans sa débilité que ça en fait une
vraie bonne merde voyez une merde bien
épaisse bien avec des cacahuètes dessus
et une cerise en haut et finalement en
voyant tout ça la vraie question qu'on
peut se poser c'est est-ce que la
franchise Resident Evil peut-être autre
chose que des mauvais films parce que
honnêtement les jeux Resident Evil ils
était super parce que c'était le
gameplay qui était super mais si tu
prends le scénario qui est l'élément de
base avec lequel est fabriqué un film
bah le scénario de Resident Evil c'était
des énormes nanards et c'est la même
raison pour laquelle un film Metal Gear
serait aussi aussi une énorme merde le
jeu nous donne cette sensation de stress
avec la difficulté à bouger les
personnages à cause de sa lourdeur des
munitions limitées des cadrage de caméra
qui joue avec le horschamp mais ça en
film c'est impossible à faire alors
est-ce qu'on peut dire finalement que ce
sont les films de Paul Anderson les
meilleurs évidemment parce que je suis
la meilleure déjà je suis super belle je
suis super forte je suis super cool vous
faites là wou qu'est-ce que tu fais dans
mon cadre là tu casses tout
[Musique]